évidemment parler de la réforme des
retraites et de cet exercice de
pédagogie d'Elizabeth borne on va en
voir plusieurs extraits d'abord Audrey
avec vous on va voir que sur la forme
Elisabeth borne a changé de méthode oui
elle parlait d'une réforme juste
désormais elle le conseille elle demande
un effort aux Français avec des éléments
de langage répété à volonté
responsabilité j'ai le courage d'eux et
puis hier c'était aussi le retour des
courbes des schémas pour expliquer que
la réforme est inévitable sinon tous
s'écroule écoutez
c'est un effort et je mesure ce que ça
représente pour beaucoup de Français
mais ma responsabilité c'est aussi de
dire la vérité aux Français de dire que
si on ne fait pas cette réforme des
retraites c'est notre système par
répartition qui ne tiendra pas voilà
dans cet extrait c'est un peu le bingo
de tous les éléments de langage de ce
que la première ministre a développé
hier pendant l'interview ouais
effectivement c'est un changement
sémantique mais il est quand même
important dans la manière dont Elizabeth
Bank s'adresse aux Français je suis pas
sûr que ça fasse beaucoup bouger les
lignes moi je pense que très
fondamentalement le l'exécutif considère
que la bataille de l'opinion sera très
difficile à gagner c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire contenu finalement de
l'oscillité assez massive que manifeste
les Français à cette réforme et il y a
peu de chance finalement que ils
arrivent à renverser en quelques
semaines cette hostilité moi je pense
que cet exercice d'abord il intervient 4
jours avant la discussion parlementaire
à l'Assemblée nationale le 6 et que que
finalement il s'adresse certes à
l'opinion mais il s'adresse peut-être
plus j'allais dire au parlementaire de
la majorité et au parlementaire
éventuellement de l'opposition comme les
républicains qui peuvent voter ce texte
plutôt qu'un à l'opinion publique après
clairement
Élisabeth borne a tenu un discours qui
était sombre qui se voulait pédagogique
je pense que là où peut-être elle a un
peu marqué un point c'est lorsque
par rapport aux positions du président
du corps et l'a dit le problème c'est
pas tant les dépenses que les recettes
là en la matière il y avait un élément
un peu nouveau dans l'expression mais
sur le fond je ne suis pas sûr que cette
intervention hier de la première
ministre change quoi que ce soit en ce
qui concerne la détermination des gens
qui se mobilisent dans la rue et en ce
qui concerne le soutiennent l'opinion
publique sur la manière de s'adresser
aux Français Olivier effectivement elle
employé plusieurs fois je tiens langage
de vérité responsabilité c'est ma
responsabilité de faire cette réforme il
faut avoir le courage de la faire ça ça
peut marcher auprès de l'opinion c'est
quelque chose que les Français ne
peuvent pas entendre en tout cas la
première version n'a pas marché très
clairement avoir et les mobilisations et
les sondages donc là on a eu hier soir
Elisabeth borne qui faisait du Born
finalement alors pas de l'irismes pas
beaucoup d'empathie du sérieux du
c'était presque une démonstration
mathématique et effectivement en
quittant imposé l'idée que finalement il
y a pas tellement de choix que personne
n'a envie de faire cette réforme que oui
par définition travail plantant c'est
demander des efforts mais que l'état du
système si on veut le conserver
nécessite de de bouger et de faire ses
efforts donc
c'est une façon de différent de de
présenter les choses effectivement
il y a pu avoir quelques flottements
dans la majorité ou dans les satellites
de la majorité il y a aussi cette idée
de dire écoutez maintenant il faut y
aller on va en parler évidemment du
débat parlementaire et de la majorité
mais sur la manière de commencé aux
Français ça veut dire que la bataille de
l'opinion elle est définitivement perdue
c'est très difficile si vous voulez de
remonter la pente quand vous avez entre
64 et 70% d'une opinion publique qui est
opposée à votre à votre texte donc ça ça
va être extrêmement compliqué je pense
que aujourd'hui la stratégie du
gouvernement c'est de considérer que de
toute façon cette bataille est
vraisemblablement perdue que la bataille
qu'il faut gagner c'est la bataille
parlementaire et qu'on se donne le moyen
sur le plan de la procédure
éventuellement aussi de la gagner et
également sur le plan j'allais dire des
manœuvres parlementaires on voit bien
que par exemple le fait que ça soit
plutôt le RL qui défend de la motion
référendaire ça arrange plutôt la
majorité en l'occurrence donc je crois
que c'est ça et il paraît récemment sur
soit un essoufflement de la mobilisation
soit le fait qu'une partie de l'opinion
publique tout en étant hostile
finalement se résignera bon après je
veux dire c'est une boîte de Pandore
quand même qui est ouverte qu'on le
voyou il peut y avoir un petit peu
d'ambivalence quand même dans l'opinion
et les sondages traduisent pas forcément
tous c'est-à-dire que on peut
individuellement dire mais moi j'ai pas
envie de travailler plus tard où je vois
qu'il y a des métiers difficiles et donc
je comprends que ces gens-là n'est pas
envie de travailler plus tard tout en
ayant dans un coin de tête l'idée parce
qu'il y a quand même malgré tout
effectivement des paramètres
mathématiques démographiques en tout cas
qui font que dans un régime ou les
actifs payent les pensions des retraités
il faut équilibrer les choses d'une
façon ou d'une autre donc je pense que
Elisabeth borne joue là-dessus sur cette
idée du côté un peu indispensable qui
encore une fois même si
et je crois que là-dessus de l'exécutif
a fait une croix sur l'idée d'avoir un
enthousiasme sur cette réforme mais
peut-être une forme d'acceptation plus
ou moins résignée sur le fond alors
Audrey parce que on attendait évidemment
ce qu'elle est dire Elizabeth borne
est-ce qu'elle est avoir des annonces
est-ce qu'elle est avoir des infections
alors bah non première ministre
inflexible si quand même des petites
annonces je vais je vais vous en parler
j'espère en tout cas que personne
n'attendait devant sa télé la fin de
l'allongement à 64 ans car s'il y a des
modifications au Parlement elles seront
à la marge pour les femmes pas d'annonce
sur les trimestres de maternité elle a
au contraire concédé que oui certaines
femmes qui n'ont pas un emploi pénible
ou une carrière longue partiront plus
tarder il y a des situations de femmes
comme vous et moi auxquelles en effet et
je pense qu'on n'est pas abîmé par le
travail vous comme moi ou on fait pardon
vous l'assumez on fait partie des six
Français sur 10 qui devront travailler
plus longtemps jusqu'à 74 ans elle
assume mais en même temps difficile de
faire autrement sans désavouer son
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
Franck Riester qui sur notre antenne a
dit que les femmes seraient un peu plus
pénalisées que les hommes par cette
réforme pour le reste la première
ministre sédite ouverte à des mesures
pour les personnes qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans puisqu'à réforme
elles devront travailler 44 ans au lieu
de 43 et c'est un gros point de blocage
pour les républicains dont elle a besoin
pour faire passer la réforme enfin sur
l'index senior elle ne s'oppose pas à ce
qu'il y ait des sanctions pour les
entreprises qui ne l'affichent pas
écoutez
alors je pense qu'on doit aller sans
doute plus loin et on a des députés de
la majorité qui le proposent et donc on
aura ce débat
dès à présent si les entreprises ne
renseignaient pas cette index on prévoit
une sanction financière mais je pense
qu'on peut aller plus loin et le débat
de la semaine prochaine sera sans doute
l'occasion de le faire en disant que les
entreprises dont l'index montre qu'elles
n'ont pas des bonnes pratiques à l'égard
des seniors si elles n'ont pas un plan
d'action elles doivent mettre en place
un plan d'action qui évidemment sera
négocié dans l'entreprise si elle ne le
font pas ou s'il n'y a pas des effets
pour corriger ces mauvaises pratiques
alors il pourra aussi y avoir des
sanctions alors on l'entend quelques
ouvertures sur l'index senior quelques
ouvertures également sur un débat sur
les carrières longues est-ce que ça peut
suffire Olivier alors clairement pas
pour rallier les syndicats Laurent
Berger qui est celui sur lequel depuis
longtemps
en tout cas au tout départ le
gouvernement esp vous allez pouvoir
compter il le disait dans Le Parisien il
y a quelques semaines tant qu'on a une
mesure qui recule l'âge quoi qu'on mette
autour il y aura pas de deal avec la
CFDT les personnes les élus en
l'occurrence que ça peut convaincre
c'est cette fraction des députés les
républicains qui
hésitent ou qui fait monter les enchères
selon la façon dont on veut le voir il
est certain que sur une réforme qui a du
mal à passer comme ça qui suscite une
telle résidence résistance dans
l'opinion l'affaire adoptée par un vote
classique donc ça nécessite le renfort
des républicains ce sera pas la même
chose que de la faire passer par ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un artifice de
procédure même c'est des choses qui
existent dans la Constitution 49-3 temps
programmé tant limité d'examen du texte
malgré tout ça ne donnera pas la même
impression de passage en force ou pas
donc je pense que c'est un point
important d'ailleurs Elisabeth band
c'est un petit peu engagé là-dessus hier
puisque elle a dit qu'elle n'envisait
pas l'hypothèse d'un 49-3 donc est-ce si
une façon de de forcer un petit peu la
main de LR en tout cas elle c'est un
petit peu avancé là-dessus on va venir
sur le débat parlementaire mais puisque
vous citiez Laurent Berger avant de
faire réagir Arnaud on va l'écouter
Laurent Berger puisque il a réagi juste
après l'intervention d'Elisabeth band
c'était toujours sur France 2 on a
l'impression de revivre la conférence de
Presse du 10 janvier en fait la
conférence de presse qui présentait la
réforme des retraites pour les nuls quoi
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a rien de bouger on
a le sentiment que entre temps il s'est
pas passé un mouvement social d'une
grande ampleur avec les manifestations
les plus nombreuses depuis le début des
années 90
donc on le voit les syndicats toujours
pas convaincus est-ce qu'elle peut y
arriver dans une situation aujourd'hui
de blocage entre les syndicats et le
gouvernement parce que de toute façon il
y a un totem qu'aucun veut bouger c'est
la question de l'âge tant du côté du
gouvernement madame borne a cessé de
répéter depuis quelques jours que
c'était non négociable elle l'a dit
dimanche dernier elle a quand même
répété implicitement hier et du côté des
syndicats y compris des syndicats les
plus réformistes comme la CFDT c'est
également non négociable donc on est
dans une situation qui est une situation
de blocage socio-politique aujourd'hui
clairement donc la vraie question c'est
de savoir comment on en sort on en sort
soit par la procédure parlementaire on
voit qu'hier quand même elle a donné en
effet un peu sur sa gauche avec la
question de l'index un peu sur sur sa
droite avec la question des gens qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt des signaux
pour que je veux dire
disposer d'une d'une majorité à
l'Assemblée est-ce que ça sera suffisant
je n'en sais rien on va voir bien sûr
c'est que la procédure aujourd'hui qui a
été retenue est une procédure qui permet
quand même d'aller vite en l'occurrence
et d'ailleurs c'est des critiques que
font notamment la nupes par rapport à
cette au choix de cette procédure donc
sur les sur les syndicats est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ça veut dire que sur le
fond effectivement on a d'un côté les
syndicats qui me disent nous on demande
qu'une chose c'est le retrait de l'âge
et Elisabeth Borg qui dit il y a une
chose qui est pas négociable c'est le
retrait de là ça peut miser sur une
division syndicale sur la suite du
mouvement clairement aujourd'hui rien ne
la seule la seule division qui puisse
aujourd'hui
au stade où nous parlons qui puisse en
effet aujourd'hui existé entre les
syndicats c'est pas tant sur l'objectif
poursuivi que sur les moyens d'action
voilà c'est ça le sujet c'est pas c'est
pas l'objectif l'objectif ils sont
d'accord sur l'objectif c'est à dire
retrait de cette disposition
c'est-à-dire de l'article 7 ils sont
parfois en effet en divergence sur les
moyens d'action maintenant la question
qui va se passer c'est de voir ce qui va
se passer cette semaine il y a deux
mobilisations une le 7 une le 11
la qualité d'action et on voit que
d'ailleurs y compris des syndicats comme
par exemple Sud Rail ont pas envie de se
mettre l'opinion à dos il y a pas de
blocage il y a pas de grève
reconductible dans les transports pour
le moment donc il y a une gêne
finalement limitée pour les Français
dans leur vie quotidienne alors ça peut
être mis au crédit de ces syndicats mais
ça peut faire aussi qu'il y a pas
d'expiration qui monte et ça peut
faciliter le travail entre guillemets
pour pour le gouvernement et puis il y a
une deuxième chose c'est que les
syndicats réformistes la CFDT mais même
des gens qui me faut par exemple sont
très républicains très légaliste et
qu'une fois que le texte sera adopté
définitivement alors c'est encore pas
tout de suite il y a du chemin mais on
les voit pas continuer à
manifester une opposition et ils sont
très respectueux de des institutions du
Parlement et donc même si ce sera avec
de la résignation et peut-être de la
colère rentrée de la part de beaucoup de
salariés à ce moment là il est probable
que tous ces syndicats là en tout cas
c'est avoir pour par exemple la CGT mais
pour cela il cesseront le mouvement
assez rapidement et vous l'avez dit le
taxi arrive lundi au Parlement vous me
l'avez un peu dit Olivier Elisabeth
bande elle s'est exprimée hier sur le
49-3 oui elle l'a répété elle va tenter
la conciliation jusqu'au bout elle
n'envisage pas l'hypothèse vous l'avez
dit d'un retour à la recours à l'article
49-3 ce sont ces termes oui mais voilà
20 000 amendements déposés rien qu'à
l'Assemblée plus l'ombre du Conseil
constitutionnel qui va sûrement demander
un vote un 49-3 pour valider un vote ou
un 49 fois pour valider le texte on
pense que c'est un voeux pieuvre c'est
un peu pieux
aujourd'hui alors qu'on va commencer la
discussion par la montée il est évident
que la première ministre qui entend
négocier avec sa majorité et LR ne peut
pas dire on passe par le 49.3 le
véhicule du 49-3 est un véhicule qui en
tout cas irritera d'ailleurs à
l'intérieur du Parlement évidemment pas
seulement les oppositions les plus
déterminées mais un certain nombre de
soutiens au sein même de la majorité
mais même parmi les LR et ensuite
véritablement je pense que
psychologiquement au moment où vous avez
2 millions de personnes dans la rue une
opinion qui est massivement opposée à
cette réforme dire qu'on va passer en
force c'est j'allais dire rajouter du
mécontentement ou de la colère à la
colère donc on peut tout à fait
comprendre aujourd'hui j'allais dire la
stratégie rhétorique au moment où l'on
parle de Madame borne ensuite bon on va
voir comment ça va se passer dans les
dans les débats je pense que c'est une
hypothèse quand même qu'il faut pas tout
à fait exclure le 49-3 sauf que
l'utilisation du 49-3 dans le moment
politiquement c'est un très mauvais
signal qui est envoyé à la fois au
parlementaire mais aussi à l'opinion
publique
moi je pense que elle sera pas forcément
obligée de dire courir je crois très peu
que tu auras beaucoup de détections dans
la majorité sur un texte si important
allez voter contre ça serait vraiment
faire ces sessions c'est un chemin sans
retour possible on voit bien par exemple
que Édouard Philippe a battu un petit
peu le rappel de de ces troupes
la question maintenant est-ce que
suffisamment de vote
ou alors effectivement est-ce qu'on
arrivera jusqu'au vote c'est une c'est
une autre question parce que ça va être
crack parce que si vous voulez d'abord
il y a quand même une partie de LR qui
aujourd'hui traîne c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire les pieds par rapport aux
consignes de la direction de LR à la
fois du président du groupe
parlementaire et aussi de Monsieur cioti
et de Monsieur retaillou ici au Sénat et
que vous avez aussi par exemple un
groupe qui va manquer à l'appel dont on
parle très peu et dont finalement le
gouvernement escompté qu'il puisse
disposer d'un certain nombre de voies
des parlementaires de ce groupe c'est le
groupe yote qui majoritairement ne va
pas voter le texte aussi semble-t-il
est-ce qu'il y a c'est que vous avez
beaucoup de parlementaires vous avez
beaucoup de parlementaires qui en effet
y compris ceux de la majorité qui sur le
terrain lorsqu'il se retrouve dans leur
circonscription entendent une partie de
leurs électeurs qui sont très remontés
contre ce texte donc c'est quand même un
exercice qui est difficile donc moi je
pense en effet que il devrait y arriver
il devrait y arriver
c'est ça centre droit centre gauche
avec les députés corps sont 30 donc vous
avez un gros plat qui massivement ne va
pas voter le texte je suis pas sûr que
toute la gauche a envie qu'on aille pas
jusqu'au vote parce que aller jusqu'à ce
fameux article 7 qui prévoit le passage
au 64 ans c'est aussi dire notamment au
député des républicains allez-y prenez
votre responsabilité les masques vont
tomber qui votent pour qui votent contre
qui s'abstient peut-être que certains à
gauche auront envie d'aller jusque là
plutôt que ça se termine effectivement
par un par un non vote par une sorte
d'adoption des facto
et sans qu'elle ait préparé le terrain à
un éventuel 49-3 parce qu'hier elle a
fait si j'ai les oppositions avec leur
très nombreux amendements elle en a elle
a même tendu la main pour que certains
en retirent donc peut-être que si 49-3
il y a elle pourra aussi dire que c'est
la faute d'exposition et de c'est très
nombreux amendements c'est aussi ça il y
a d'un côté l'opposition qui dépose un
très grand nombre d'amendements pour
pousser au 49-3 et Elizabeth Bank il dit
c'est la faute de très grand nombre
d'amendements si on a 49,3 bien sûr elle
pourra leur envoyer leur envoyer la
balle et leur dire si vous n'aviez pas
pratiqué cette forme d'obstruction on
aurait pu débattre du fond et de ce
recul de l'âge des figures classiques
une figure classique il y a obstruction
il y a eu des moi j'ai connu des textes
qui où il y avait beaucoup plus
d'amendements je rappelle la
privatisation de Gaz de France en 2006
si mes souvenirs sont bons c'est je
crois 160 000 amendements qui sont
déposés par les oppositions même la
réforme précédente des retraites a donné
lieu à un dépôt d'amendement beaucoup
plus important près de 40 000 donc bon
si vous voulez après évidemment elle a
beau jeu de dire regardez il y a un
nombre d'abondement
conséquent plus que conséquent exagéré
qui qui est déposé donc il y a
obstruction c'est une c'est une attitude
irresponsable de l'opposition Olivier
vous parliez d'edorph-philippe on va
l'écouter puisque peu un peu ce peu
avant son intervention et Isabelle borne
a reçu le soutien de son ancien Premier
ministre Édouard Philippe un soutien
sans ambiguïté sans bémol c'est ce qu'a
dit le patron d'horizon qui en a profité
pour lancer un message au parlementaire
on se pose souvent la question de est-ce
que c'est une réforme juste comme je
comprends très bien qu'on se pose la
question c'est pas une mauvaise question
mais ce qui me surprend c'est qu'on
oublie de se poser la question de savoir
si le système actuel est juste prenons
garde que
soucieux de faire en sorte que la
réforme soit mieux acceptée et soucieux
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
justice ce qui n'est jamais en mauvais
objectif nous perdions de vue
l'impératif d'équilibre du système
il est clair là le message d'Édouard
Philippe qui s'adresse y compris aux
député d'horizon vous pouvez améliorer
si vous le souhaitez mais attention
l'objectif c'est la sauvegarde du
système l'équilibre du système c'est
assez habile ce qui fait parce qu'il
renverse la question de l'injustice en
la ramenant aussi au système actuel au
passage ça lui permet de dire en creux
mais moi je portais une réforme qui
devait mettre fin à ses indigestifs qui
étaient plus ambitieuses ont été
tellement ambitieuse que on n'a pas
réussi à la faire passer elle était sans
doute très compliquée aussi mais enfin
au final ça lui il arrive à cet appel
clair à voter la réforme je vois pas
comment il aurait pu faire autrement
entre nous c'est une question de
cohérence et Édouard Philippe il y a
encore quelques mois plaider pour aller
à 65 voir 66 ou 67 ans dire qu'une
réforme qui qui porte l'âge légal à 64
ans ne va pas dans le bon sens on là il
aurait perdu toute cette cohérence et on
n'aurait pas compris où il voulait en
venir c'est exactement le même problème
qui se pose au groupe mais on
l'entendait pas jusque là Édouard
Philippe parce que là sa prise de parole
peut changer quelque chose il n'a pas le
choix de toute façon il y a aucun des
responsables de la majorité
à d'autres choix que celui qui a été
exprimé par Édouard Philippe
c'est-à-dire de soutenir cette réforme
parce que finalement aujourd'hui
exprimer des réserves c'est prendre le
risque en effet qu'à certains nombre de
parlementaires qui sont déjà tentés par
le fait de s'abstenir voire de voter
contre finalement passer à l'acte la
réalité c'est que lui il est pas
parlementaire donc ça c'est une chose il
est président d'une formation politique
bon après moi ce que j'entends dire
c'est
un certain nombre de parlementaires
d'horizon qui émettent et qui émettent
un certain nombre de réserves quant à la
pertinence du texte est-ce que la parole
d'Édouard Philippe sera suffisamment
forte pour que le groupe parlementaire
horizon dans sa totalité votre texte et
bon on va le voir très rapidement on
peut l'imaginer si vous enlevez Édouard
Philippe d'horizon il reste pas grand
chose donc si le si le chef est-ce
qu'elle va vraiment pouvoir par le
compter sur le soutien de l'ensemble de
sa majorité parce que il y a des députés
d'horizon qui ne sont pas chauds pour
voter la réforme il y a François Bayou
aussi qui fait quand même entendre
même des députés renaissances qui disent
on n'est pas sûr de la voter est-ce
qu'elle va vraiment pouvoir compter sur
sa majorité François Bayrou il a
l'habitude de faire entendre sur plein
de sujets sa petite musique et puis au
final je pense en tête ces derniers mois
qui soit allé jusqu'au fait que son
groupe n'est pas suivi la majorité et
que ça mis en danger un texte donc et
après il peut y avoir quelques
tentations individuelles sur l'algo du
groupe Renaissance je ne dis pas que ça
n'arrivera pas simplement c'est députés
là encore une fois devront réfléchir
de façon profonde à ce qui s'apprête à
faire parce que comment revendiquer
ensuite l'appartenance à la majorité
macroniste en ayant voté contre un texte
d'une telle importance portée par la
première ministre de façon si visible et
puis c'était dans le projet
présidentielle on a une campagne très
courte il s'est pas passé grand chose
mais ce point là était dit clairement
par Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne
donc ça me semble quand même délicat
sauf encore une fois à dire je quitte la
majorité sauf que l'opinion sauf que
sauf que l'opinion ne l'a pas entendu
comme ça c'est-à-dire que l'opinion a
voté enfin une majorité de Français ont
voté pour Emmanuel Macron au second tour
on ne lui donnant pas inquiétude sur la
réforme des retraites ce qui est clair
c'est que tout va dépendre finalement de
la dynamique des mobilisations des
semaines qui viennent et notamment de la
semaine prochaine si les mobilisations
sont très fortes s'il y a une
augmentation de la mobilisation
notamment le 11 si l'opinion publique
continue à soutenir le mouvement voire
cette cette opposition croit encore dans
l'opinion ça peut avoir un impact sur le
vote d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires le Parlement n'est pas un
espace sanctuarisé qui est insensible à
ce qui se passe dans la société et on
suivra bien sûr tout ça
[Musique]